eux ne veulent pas du passage de la
deuxième ligne du tramway tour en jour
devant leur porte eux ce sont les
membres du collectif contre le tram par
le boulevard Jean Royer ils se sont
donnés rendez-vous samedi matin pour
exprimer leur mécontentement et
placarder des affiches contre le maire
de Tours ce tracé par ailleurs
nécessiterait selon l'abattage de
nombreux arbres Aurélie Renaud quand on
fait des relevés il y a bien dit 10
degrés d'écart entre le côté du
boulevard
arboré et le côté en face voilà 60
arbres abattus pour faire passer un tram
impossible à imaginer pour les membres
du collectif contre le tram boulevard
Jean Royer ils invitent les riverains à
dénoncer la bataille via des affichettes
mais au-delà des arbres c'est le passage
du tramway devant leur maison qui coince
le tramway de vu la largeur de ma rue
passerait juste au niveau de mes
fenêtres de mon salon donc les gens
pourraient se faire coucou que si vous
voulez continuer quand ils passeront
tous les matins je pourrais leur dire
bonjour et en même temps comme c'est
très haut le tramway il pourrait presque
voir ma salle de bain quoi le collectif
est plusieurs livres remettent en
quête tramway
encore temps d'imaginer
boulevard Jean Royer il faut un nouveau
moyen de transport c'est là-dessus que
je viens d'insister sauver les armes
c'est encore mieux mais d'abord il nous
faut un moyen de transport et si le
moyen de transport en fait peut être
autre celui qui est proposé aujourd'hui
notamment un relais entre le tramway
existant et d'autres moyens de transport
je pense que ça serait une meilleure
solution et est-ce que la fréquentation
du tram
officiellement prévu on sait pas trop
par quel statistique et vraiment réel le
coût annoncé le coût prévisible on
avoisinerait les 800 millions d'euros le
coût annoncé de ce tramway est
faramineux et voire même pharaonique
on a des propositions alternatives et
c'est de ça aussi qu'on veut discuter
avec les élus avec le préfet le
collectif devrait rencontrer les
institutions et le préfet ces prochaines
semaines d'ici là d'autres actions de
mobilisation auront lieu boulevard Jean
Royer